hello everyone and welcome to a video
that is basically a tribute to a
gentleman named Erika Gottlieb Elis
Casas he's a gentleman who has
represented the Austria Germany and
Argentina throughout his chess career
and he has been one of the strongest
players in the world uh in the era that
he was playing in seriously this is the
first game we are going to show is again
a former world champion Jose rule
capablanca who I believe does not need
any introduction was played in 1937 as
it says above the board in semening
Baden and it's uh it's really a
remarkable game the other game that we
are going to show is against the Bobby
Fischer from the Buenos Aires Tournament
of 1960 and
um uh it's very hard to imagine that
there exists a person who is even able
to defeat one of these these German I'm
talking about capablanca and Fisher let
alone uh both of them which is
absolutely incredible and you could
argue okay this is perhaps not Peak our
capablanca and Peak power Fisher as he
played capablanca in 1937 and he played
the Fisher in 1960 Fisher was 17 years
old then but let's not forget that
fisher already played in the candidates
tournament team as a 16 year old and he
was already well established as one of
the strongest players in the world now
the other thing that is very very hard
to imagine that okay someone actually
has defeated both capablanca and Fisher
the the the the uh Elise cases is a
stronger suit was the end game he he
really loved playing the end game and he
was extremely strong in the end game but
so were capablanca and Fisher so it's
really remarkable what will happen in
these two games I'm gonna show both of
the games in one video so it will
perhaps be a bit of a longer video but
you can you know watch first if you
don't have time you can watch one game
and then the other game but the games
are absolutely incredible so let's dive
straight into it uh and oh yeah like I
said one of the strongest players in the
world uh at one point over course of
1938 and 1939 Eddie had a streak of
eight consecutive tournaments where he
went without a single loss he did not
lose a single game and he was considered
uh as uh as a contender for the title
against Alexandra
wanted to face either Ellis causes or
maybe even Paul Pierce's uh Kerris was
also truly an amazing young player but
then uh came the outbreak of the World
War II and uh well then it didn't happen
then at least causes went to Argentina
and later on he he or okay he couldn't
play uh uh up on the level where he
could play in 1939 and 1938 but okay
that being said let's check out the
first game against Jose capablanca uh
the 1937 one from uh simmering Baden he
opens with Pawn to D4 capablanca plays
D5 we have C for C6 Knight to F3 and
Knight to F6 uh the slav defense is on
the board we have Knight to see 3 and D
captures on C4 we have Pawn to A4 now
stopping B5 and Bishop to F5 now this is
um all very well known the check
variation of the alapin uh we have
Knights the E5 and now Knight beta D7 by
capablanca Knight captures on C4 and
queen to C7 uh now the queen is very
nicely placed here uh controlling this
long diagonal so G3 preparing Bishop to
afford to this logical Queen from C7 and
now Pawn to E5 capablanca prevents this
with the captors Knight captures uh and
now of course the bishop to F4 so he has
the Knight and C4 is hanging but so is
your queen if you move the Knight so
Knight after D7 adding another Defender
and Bishop to G2 by Eddie and now uh F6
this is uh still uh the uh the very
popular move today as is this line but
nowadays even G5 is um very much
playable because it's a very sharp line
you of course cannot move the bishop
because then you blunder the Knight but
you can however play Knight the E3
attack the undefended bishop on F5 and
let's after captures captures both
players will Castle black will Castle
Queen said white will castle kingside
and you have this crazy position where
white will attack on the queen side
black will attack on the king side not
something that capablanca is looking for
in this game so he plays the component
F6 and now we have castles we have Rook
to d8 now aligning The Rook nicely with
the queen and the queen to C1 with
Bishop to E6 now adding another attacker
to the Knight here and not just Knight
captures on E5 we have Knight captures
and pawn to A5 grabbing more space here
already done uh mess up a black spawn
structure on the queen side with fonte
A6 so black plays A6 and now Knight the
E4 uh an excellent Square for the knight
uh also the Knight can come to C5 at
some point the B7 point is a backward
spawn so if you can get your knight to
C5 play B4 this is a permanent weakness
so Bishop to B4 uh Kappa Blanca develops
the the bishop goes after the A5 pawn
and now Bishop back to DQ you defend uh
the the pawn this way and uh the
position has been reached once but it
has been reached in in this exact same
tournament capablanca was playing the
black pieces against uh Ruben fine the
game ended in a draw and capablanca
continued with the bishop captures on D2
but here Copa Blanca tries Queen to E7
and it is now as of move 17 that this
position has never been reached again so
Bishop captures on B4 uh capablanca
recapters Queen captures on B4 and now
Queen to C5 uh Eric just says I'm now
ready to play in end game against
capablanca that that's exactly what what
I've said and you you have to trade
there's really no uh no good way to
avoid this you could try to trade uh
with Queen to D4 but capturing on B2 is
impossible if you try this just Knight
the D6 check and now if you go anywhere
along the dark squares the Knight will
pick up the queen with check you cannot
go to F7 you can play this but then just
Rook B1 Queen moves and Rook captures on
B7 will be Checkmate so Kappa Blanca has
to trade Queen scare we have Queen
characters Knight captures the B7 Pawn
is hanging and Bishop to c8u force
capablancas Bishop to a bit of a passive
square but okay I mean uh this is what I
find remarkable how happy can one be
going into a slightly better end game
against capablanca well that's just the
the kind of a player that Eric causes
was so here Bishop to C8 we have Rook
after D1 offering a rook trade and now
King to E7 the king doesn't have the
castle uh the king is uh very much okay
on a nice active square like he's 7 B3
okay I know B4 is also an option but you
can always play B4 for the moment let's
take away the C4 Square from the Black
Knight Knight Knight Knight to F7 by
capablanca and now Ponte E4 grabbing the
center F4 is coming and then in the
future E5 and F5 will be an option uh
Rook to D6 preparing to double up on the
D file and now uh uh Eddie just trade so
Rook captures and now you might be
expecting Knight captures but capablanca
uh the Exquisite endgame player that he
has plays King captures on D6 this comes
with Tempo the Knight is hanging so
white will have to spend the move to
defend it and then you will play King to
C7 free and freeing up the the light
Square Bishop from the defense of the B7
Pawn so Pawn to B4 and now King the C7
this is how capablanca shifts his King
over to the queen side Rook to D1 and
now Kappa Blanca also counters that with
Rook to d8 we have Rook captures on d8
Knight capture 78 and onto F4 and now
you have this end game with equal
material both player is an item Bishop
however White's position is a little bit
better he has constant pressure against
that B7 Pawn uh so the you have to keep
an eye on it also you can put a knight
on B6 could be very annoying and also
you have a very natural way of how you
want to play this you want to get the
king to D4 and then make black software
so here are Copa Blanca says nope I'm
not playing that game just Pawn to B6 he
gets rid of his weakness eight
characters we have King captures and now
Bishop to F1 this is a crucial move in
White's plan of uh just continuing the
game without Bishop to F1 a couple
Blanca's Position will just be better
but now with the pawn covering A5 and C5
and Bishop covering B5 you are keeping
the king and B6 you can always kick it
away with Knight to A4 and the pawns
here will be nicely controlled by this B
for Pawn so here at night the E6
capablanca offers a trade of knights and
knights the A4 check forcing the black
king back King to C7 and now King to F2
the king now wants to come as deep into
the position as possible and the way to
play this and there is only one good way
to play this however it doesn't amount
to more than a draw a capablanca should
play C5 here and everything just gets
traded off he he wins the C6 Square for
his King for example B captures now you
can even play Bishop D7 attack the
Knight and if Knight the B6 even Bishop
C6 to go after the E4 Pawn this is how
uh you should play this for example E5
captures captures Knight captures on C5
and now Knight to C4 equal material not
much uh for for either side black has a
past April and white has a past E Pawn
uh should um uh resolve in a nice draw
but capablanca obviously wanted more
than a draw he played G5 uh probably
thinking that uh elizaz although he he
probably knew he was a a very strong
player didn't think that there was a
chance for capablanca to actually lose
this game okay he might not win but he's
not gonna lose but okay King the E3 yeah
Eric star uh continues bringing the king
into the game G captures an F for G
captures and now Knights the G7 by
capablanca uh but now he gives up the C5
Square uh for for the White Knight so
Knights the C5 and now the problem is
yes you can defend the A6 Pawn by
playing something like King to B6 but
then King D4 and this king is now a
monster for example Knight the E6 check
you can trade captures captures E5 and
it resigns for capablanca for example as
capture skin captures the bishop is
attack now the epon F1 marches forward
there is there's no stopping this so
after Knight the C5 uh capablanca goes
back Knight to E6 so it seems like he's
giving up the A6 Pawn uh but first we
have Knight captures on E6 Bishop
captures and now not the bishop captures
on A6 but King to D4 it's uh more
important to activate your king if your
king reaches C5 then it's just game over
so King to B6 and now Bishop to C4 uh
Eric just shows how how dominant his
position is uh because if if you trade
uh it's completely lost and if you don't
trade it's also uh completely lost but
still you you have to find a very
particular set of moves because if you
trade let's say captures captures uh the
pawn cannot be pushed if you push this
Pawn we just capture it if you push this
point you capture and play King C5 if
you do nothing then E5 will create a
pass Pawn so
and not much to be done here so after
Bishop the C4 Bishop to G4 a nice
attempt by Kappa Blanca and now E5 we
have F captures on E5 with check F
captures Now Pawn to H6 and pawn to H4
with Bishop to H5 and now Pawn to E6 now
the king is also ready to uh jump deeper
into the position uh Bishop to E8 and
now Bishop to D3 with King the C7 and
now King to C5 putting extreme pressure
on capablanca's position uh Bishop to H5
and now comes Bishop to H7 uh here
Bishop captures an A6 is winning uh but
um Eddie decides to do it uh uh well in
a bit of a different fashion although
this will allow capablanca some drawing
chances uh Bishop to G4 what was his
plan Ponte E7 and down after King to D7
now his idea was Bishop to E4 and the
bishop captures on C6 was will happen uh
then he will win this one and then he
will have the past B Pawn so that's the
plan King captures an E7 we have bishop
captress and C6 and now Bishop to E2 uh
by preventing the black king from
reaching the pawn bishop to B7 and now
King to D7 we have King to B6 ready to
win the pawn and now King to D6 uh Eddie
he does win the pawn bishop captures an
A6 and now Bishop to F3 of course you
cannot trade as the oppon is too quick
uh we have King the A5 and now you will
see just how strong capablanca is in the
end game he's down upon in what appears
to be a completely lost position but he
finds a way to complicate Bishop to C6
and now if you play Bishop to B5 of
course we just captured Bishop captures
Bishop captures and
um Eddie has a light score Bishop uh
even if you lose this Pawn uh you still
have to Queen your Pawn on a dark square
a couple Blanca will just put the King
on h8 and there's no way to kick the
king away as you only have a light
Square but this isn't what I'm talking
about Bishop to B5 offering a bishop
trade now Bishop back to F3 with Bishop
to D3 now comes Bishop back to C6 so how
is uh Eric to advance this Pawn forward
he has to figure it out Bishop to C2 we
have King to C7 now comes Bishop to A4
again capablanca cannot afford to trade
of Bishops Bishop to F3 and only now B5
with King to B7 and pawn to B6 so B6 is
a dark Square your Pawn is extremely
safe here with Bishop to E2 uh and now
uh Bishop the C2 you might think uh but
when I just Bishop the B5 followed by
Bishop to A6 check well here even though
uh capablanca is down upon this is still
a draw if you if you play this then
Bishop captures King captures and now
look at this Ponte H5 incredible uh King
C5 King to B8 look at this King to D5
King B7 King to E5 King captures and now
the problem is King F5 King to C6 King
G5 King to D6 King captures on H5 uh
black is in time to
um to get the uh to the h8 or G8 squares
with King to G6 King to f8 and now you
don't have a way of uh playing this if
you go here then you block your own Pawn
that's a draw uh and if you play H5 then
just King to G8 H6 King to h8 and now H7
will be stalemate so this is uh how
capablanca wants to trick him Bishop to
B5 is just a draw so Bishop back to C2
by Eric and now we have Bishop to F3
Bishop to D3 and now Bishop to G2 Bishop
to A6 check now this is playable King to
C6 and now the problem is there is only
one way to win this position and you
guys will
um uh try to try to spot this this is
one of a uh uh one one of a kind
opportunity for you to actually beat
capablanca in an end game so feel free
to pause the video and win the game for
Eric uh while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible brilliancy and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Bishop to C8 that's the only move
that wins the game and this is how it
happens now if uh Edith can play King to
A6 King to A7 is game over so Bishop to
F1 capablanca has to prevent the king
from coming to A6 uh Bishop to G4 now we
have Bishop to D3 and now comes Bishop
to F3 with check King to D6 and now
Bishop to B7 cutting off the black king
from ever reaching that pawn bishop to
E2 and now Bishop to A6 offering a trade
of versions but now it would be winning
for Eric so Bishop to F uh sorry not
Bishop to F1 Bishop to F3 uh uh keeping
an under B7 Square uh so if you advance
the pawn the king can come to C7 now
comes Bishop to F1 with Bishop to B7 and
now Bishop to H3 and now if you go King
to C6 X the problem is just Bishop to B2
check hangs the bishop so here King the
E7 you have to play something uh now
comes King to B5 King to D6 trying to
stop the white king but now Bishop to F5
and you have to play something the
problem is uh when Eric played the
bishop to H3 he took away the C8 Square
from capablanca's Bishop and you really
don't have a way of keeping the white
King off of that A6 Square so King to E7
but now you sacrifice the C5 Square
Bishop back to GQ now comes Bishop to C8
we have King to d8 attacks the bishop
Bishop to A6 and now Bishop to F3
capablanca still hanging on but now King
to D6 and now once you've cut off the
black king completely now you can shift
your attention towards the H6 Pawn
that's that's really what it takes to
win this end game so Bishop to G2 with
Bishop to C4 and now King the C8 uh
interestingly if you go back Bishop to
B7 then Bishop D5 just offers a trade
and Bishop the C8 now you play Bishop to
C6 you completely cut off the black king
and if Bishop to A6 now you play Bishop
to D7 and once in Bishop to V7 lands now
you play Bishop to E6 and and that's
pretty much it there's nothing you can
do the the the the king can't really go
anywhere if you go here then King to C7
if you move the bishop then you get to
the C6 Square uh uh no no way to play
this so instead after Bishop to C4 King
to C8 was attempted by Kappa Blanca but
now Bishop to D5 finally winning that B7
Square Bishop to B1 and now King the E6
now you go after the H6 Pawn with Bishop
to E2 King to F6 we have King to D7 and
now King to G6 capablanca can't save the
pawn with Pawn to H5 but now the pawn is
on a light Square so the light Square
Bishop will also be able to attack at
King G5 with King to D6 and Bishop to F7
attacking the H5 Pawn King to C6 and now
Bishop captures an H5 and he was in this
position unmove 82 that Jose roll
capablanca resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here for those
of you who are interested why this is
now just game over because after yes you
will win the B6 Pawn the problem is
let's say Bishop B checking capture some
B6 and H5 uh you only have one light
Square to cross that's the H7 square and
it's very easy for uh White to dodge the
bishop on D3 so there's really nothing
for you to do king C5 H6 and once you
try something King D6 or something
Bishop to G6 cuts off the Bishop from
the defense of the H7 pawn and then the
pawn just queens and you win the game so
truly a remarkable
uh showing by Eric Helix causes uh
against the former World chess champion
Jose roll capablanca these are the
standings of this tournament if you guys
are interested so you can see it was won
by Paul Karis with nine points Reuben
fine 8 out of 14 and capablanca tied in
third with Samuel rashevski with seven
and a half out of 14 followed by Solomon
flora and Elis cases and Vladimir Petrov
so truly some of the epic names of Chess
history but it was a very important
victory for uh erigalis causes as he
really dealt a deadly blow to Copa
Blanca who without this loss would be
only half a point behind the first first
place Paul quieres but now after this
game we shift our attention to some uh
what it would say this was the 1937 so
uh 23 years after this game uh Elise
Casas will face another monster uh Bobby
Fischer or Robert James Fisher if you
will let me just update uh this uh here
for a second uh
have to update my interface uh so very
very tough game and interestingly even
in this game uh Elise causes uh just
goes for a very early end game against
Bobby Fischer so truly truly a
remarkable end game player so let's see
what happened in this one as like I said
this is already uh even though yes okay
this was maybe one of Bobby Fisher's
worst tournaments ever uh but did this
game Fisher played extremely well as you
will see uh so this does not take away
anything from from this Victory from
Ellis causes so uh Pawn to C4 with
capablanca he opened with the D4 against
Fisher he opened with C4 so you might be
thinking okay he's not an E4 player but
he defeated the groomfield with Ponte E4
so he plays everything and he can do
everything so Pawn to C4 that we have
Knight to F6 by Fisher Knight to C3 and
Ponte E6 now we have Knight to F3 and
pawn to D5 we have uh Ponte D4 and
Bishop to B4 the goals and defenses on
the board Queen to B3 challenges the
bishop and now Knights the C6 nicely
defending Bishop to G5 and now Pawn to
H6 challenging this bishop and here uh
Elise captures the Knight on F6 here a
Fisher is also testing his theory
knowledge because if you go back as I
imagine some of you do in your bullet
games online uh it's just really bad uh
black will play G5 and after G3 then G4
uh traces away the Knight and after we
move the Knight just Knight captures on
D4 it doesn't matter that Bishop is
hanging because if you capture the
bishop Knight C2 check and you blunder
the queen and now I'm not saying this is
what you guys do online but uh you know
now I hope it doesn't happen to you so
after H6 Bishop captures an F6 showing
that he of course knows his theory very
well Queen captures an F6 and pawn to E3
at the characters on C4 we have Bishop
captures and now uh Castle's King side
we have castles King side and Bishop to
E7 uh this is a pretty standard that
goes in move uh bringing the queen back
to help out with the defense of the
bishop and now Knights the A5 is the
thread going after the queen and the
bishop I always call this move the uh
the anti-evance move because uh in the
Evans Gambit you will have a queen on B3
and Bishop and C4 and you always have to
worry about Knight to the A5 move it's
like the only move that counters the
Evans Gambit so Queen back to C2 not
interested in giving up the light Square
Bishop we have Bishop to D6 by Fisher
and the Rook 8 to D1 and now uh there
are a couple of moves that were played
in this position but after King they
trade by Fisher it is now as of move 12
that this position has never been
reached again uh so here uh we have Pawn
to A3 you could also consider E4 with
the idea of E5 then uh Fisher will play
something like E5 then you get the the
D5 Square for your knight but it's
actually very similar to what happens in
the game here A3 are preparing B4 also
stopping Knight to B4 Fisher strikes in
the center with E5 Knight to D5 attacks
Fisher's queen queen to E8 and now D
captures an E5 we have Knight captures
Knight captures Queen captures Fisher is
already threatening Checkmate and now
Pawn to F4 this is possible as the
Knight is still defending the E3 Pawn so
Queen to E8 and now you have to get rid
of the spawn from E3 because C6 and then
you just blunder the pawn so Pawn to E4
with Fanta C6 challenges the Knight
Knight back to C3 and now Bishop back to
C7 as the bishop and D6 was hanging so
Queen to E2 and now we have Bishop to E6
country in the bishop and C4 we have
Ponte E5 and now Queen to E7 uh Queen to
E7 a very tricky move by Fisher uh point
is that if F5 which is kind of what
white wants to do then Queen to C5 check
blunders the bishop and C4 so instead
after Queen E7 we have knighted the E4
uh and now Rook a to d8 Fischer develops
The Rook King the H1 a nice prophylactic
move getting rid of that um nasty uh
Queen C5 maneuver idea we have Rook F
the E8 and now uh Eric just trades with
Bishop captures Queen captures and
Knight to C5 now challenges the queen
also the B7 Pawn is hanging
interestingly how even in the game
against capablanca
Erie just focused on that B7 Pawn so
Queen back to C8 and now Queen to H5
going after the F7 Pawn but here at
Fisher does not defend the pawn directly
he defends it with a tactic Rook
character's on D1 Rook captures and Rook
to d8 making it impossible for the pawn
to be captured because if you trade
Rooks and try to capture the pawn you're
just gonna get the checkmated uh as uh
King H1 might not have been such a great
prophylactic move I mean it was but just
not you know for this position so H3
creating some breeding room for the king
and now King to G8 fish sure defends the
F7 Pawn Rook captures 98 with Queen
characters and now Ponte E6 goes after
that F7 Pawn uh Queen to E7 defends the
pawn and now Queen to F5 uh we have Pawn
to B6 getting rid of that weakness
challenging the Knight here he captures
an F7 Queen captures and now Queen to C8
with check King the H7 and now comes
Knight to E6 uh attacking the bishop
here so Bishop to D6 still you cannot
capture because the Knight hangs now
comes spawn to G4 and yes uh I hear Eric
is exposing his King a little bit but as
long as the queen is unable to do
anything about it it is perfectly fine
so that's exactly what Fisher tries to
do he plays Queen to F6 he wants to pick
up the B2 Pawn we have Queen to D7 and
now Queen to E7 Fischer offers a trade
uh and Eric obliges Queen captures an E7
Bishop captures and now Knights to D4
goes after the C6
C5 and not Knight to C6 attacks the
bishop and the A7 pawn and again Fisher
finds a way to defend the pawn with a
tactic Bishop D6 now if Knight captures
Bishop captures an F4 but interestingly
that's exactly what Eddie does Bishop
Knight captures an A7 Bishop captures an
F4 is what you would think Fisher will
play but Fisher plays a very nasty move
Pawn to C4
and now there's a there's a big problem
if F5 is plated which is kind of the
move you want to play because the pawn
is hanging here then Fisher playing the
bishop captures on A3 and now uh Fisher
is just winning you cannot capture
because uh C3 and the pawn is
Unstoppable and if you don't just Bishop
captures followed by C3 C2 and C1 so
there are uh complications here and
Eddie has to figure out a way around
them he plays Knight the C8 he attacks
the bishop and also the B6 Pawn so now
Bishop captures an A3 is not as potent
um uh since uh uh well uh is not as
potent since the the B6 Pawn will be
hanging as well so here uh Fisher played
Bishop to C5 if you guys are interested
okay we can even show Bishop captures
Knight captures on B6 captures on B2
Knight captures on C4 and if you attack
the pawn pawn to F5 and uh there there's
really nothing here okay you're up one
Pawn uh but you are not winning the same
game so Fisher tried after Knight to see
it this of the C5 he defends the pawn
and now uh he he keeps the knight at Bay
here uh as you can see the Knight
doesn't really have all that many
squares okay you can go to the A7 but
the problem is the position is
completely winning now I will not tell
you why you will tell me why so feel
free to pause the video and help Eric
Harris defeat another uh future world
champion while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
incredible maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Pawn to A4 this is the only move that
wins the game and uh well here Eric just
outplays another uh another Legend uh in
of Chess uh in the end game the problem
is if you play anything else other than
uh Ponte for let's say you start
bringing the king into the game you
allow B5 and once B5 is played it's just
not the same King to F3 Bishop to D4
goes after the pawn and okay you can go
Knight to D6 Bishop characters on B2
Knight captures here but now upon the C3
uh Knight to D4 the C2 square is covered
and uh well this will likely result in a
draw after something like Bishop capture
783 equal material this will be a draw
uh so uh instead after Bishop to C5 A4
was played and now Fisher is in big
trouble he starts bringing the king into
the game but so does Eric King to G2 we
have King to F6 King to F3 uh King the
E6 and now King the E4 uh taking away
some very very important squares from
the black king Bishop to F2 and now Pawn
the F5 with check with King the D7 now
Knight to A7 we have King to D6 but now
Knight to B5 with check King to C5 and
now Knight to C7 and the problem is if
you go King to B4 then 98 you capture
this pawn and then this Pawn just
promotes the at the victory so Bishop to
H4 uh you have to be ready to defend the
G7 Pawn but still Knight to E8 we have
King the B4 now if you go Bishop to F6
it seems like yeah it's perfectly fine
but the resulting endgame is completely
winning for white because you have H4 G5
and the pawns are just too advanced like
H4 King to B4 You're Gonna Play G5 F
captures H Captain so now it doesn't
matter if you capture or push just F6 F6
and the df1 is Unstoppable so after
Knight the 8 with King the B4 by Fisher
now comes King to D5 now if you capture
uh Eddie captures on C4 we have Bishop
to E7 and not Knight captures on G7
Bishop to F6 going after the B2 Pawn
Knights the E8 and now Bishop capture
some B2 and now Fisher also has a pass C
Pawn Ponte F6 you have to give up your
Bishop for for the pawn bishop captures
we have Knight captures on F6 and now
Pawn to C3 and it seems like Fisher
sacrificed a piece and now his uh
opponent is just winning the game the
problem is it's just not there is one
move that wins the game for uh elizaz
and now for the third and final time
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Eric while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh you know just
realizing the the reality of things that
the king is not fast enough to to catch
the past Pawn so of course it has
something to do with the Knight it's
only a matter of figuring out what uh
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is night the H5 this
is the only move that wins and of course
uh Eric played it now the problem is C2
runs into Knights the F4 and after C1
Queen this runs into Knight to D3 check
uh the King was nicely placed on B4 but
just not that nice King captures an A4
Knight captures on C1 you're up a full
piece of course you are winning the game
just H for G5 H for G5 and that's it so
Fischer tried King captures on A4 but it
doesn't help him Knight to F4 we have
Ponta B5 Knight to E2 Now Pawn to C2 uh
and it was in this position after
playing Pawn to C2 that uh Fisher
realized that there really is nothing
more to be done here and he was in this
position that Robert James Fisher
resigned the game so for those of you
who are interested in how the position
might have continued uh just Pawn to H4
and that's pretty much it G5 wins the
game if B4 you're gonna play King to C4
and if B3 now you're gonna play King to
C3 and if King to A3 yes it looks very
promising uh G5 and if B2 you're gonna
cap run C2 and now of course King covers
B1 but after King to A2 covering B1
there's always Knight the C3 check and
the King has to go back doesn't really
matter where you can even go to A1 but
then just G captures and H6 the pawn is
winning once you bring the queen into
the game yes you will give up the night
but I mean I give up the queen uh
dislodge the Knight but doesn't really
matter the the queen comes into the game
and that's it so of course it was in
this position after C2 that Bobby
Fischer resigned and this is how uh
Erica elizaz defeated both uh both world
champions former world champion Jose
roll capablanca uh back in 1936 and the
future world champion or was it 1937
that game let me just check on one trick
you guys yeah it was in 1937 and a
future world champion Robert James
Fisher in 1960. and like I said okay you
could argue that
um uh maybe capablanca wasn't in Peak
power in 1937 uh but you've seen uh the
at the standings of that tournament I
mean capablanca in third place ahead of
rashevsky floor uh goes in Petrov and if
if not for this slots which really
crippled capablanca's position in the
standings he would have a second place
with eight and a half points I mean uh
behind Paul Karis who was uh I mean who
who who was uh the the one of the
strongest players in the world you know
when I say one of the strongest I mean
one of the top three players in the
world throughout the entire chess
history so uh yeah capablanca was not a
week by any means in 1937 so it was an
incredible Victory and even Bobby
Fischer here uh which was okay this was
one of the worst tournaments of his
career you can see that uh I mean it was
it was a fine game but but we played a
fine end game but Alice cars has just
out played in spawning too only winning
moves uh uh which were which were not
that that simple to find that this A4
move that Bobby missed uh and uh here in
this position uh after C3 this Knight to
H5 movie this was uh I mean it's not not
a difficult move to find uh but uh the
point is uh Eric uh found absolutely
everything he had to in that uh Fisher
Challenger challenged him with uh to
actually win this game uh so yeah uh
truly incredible and like I said in the
beginning of the video uh Alexis is not
the only member of the of the Kappa
Blanca Fisher club uh there are three
other players who have also defeated
both Bobby Fischer and Jose row
capablanca uh they are Paul Karis Samuel
rashevski and former world champion Max
so uh just you know to increase your
vast knowledge a little bit uh so yeah
that's the game or rather those were the
games hope you guys enjoyed them and the
the nice pause the video moment you see
now uh when you go out to you know with
your friends at the bar in the library
you can tell them about it
uh the a true Master of the end game who
has out and not just the defeated the
Fisher and capablanca okay they could
have had a really bad day blunt or
something but no he took them into an
equal end game and just outplayed them
that is something very few people can
say and that's why he was one of the
strongest players in the world and a
contender for the title of world chess
champion uh so yeah that's the game and
a little bit of History hope you guys
enjoyed that story for a bit of a longer
video but I I mean it's impossible too
very very uh long games including the
incredible end games so it had to be a
bit longer I would like to thank Cassius
Johnson Robert Trenton Rodney Barr
bullet King and lydney brenza for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day